[Music]
I fetched dream news far-fetched dream
that's like my life what a cuddly dark
really I thought it was bar this yeah
you think a lot of yourself it's like my
life is a far-fetched dream for most
people ah even the most far-fetched life
to come we have far-fetched dreams too
that's true I wish I had a vagina to
shout out golden eggs why would you want
your vagina to [ __ ] I want golden guy I
just saw Dookie that's covered in one
coming up just a butthole in her [ __ ]
hole I just want to be able to [ __ ] out
like Faberge eggs and just be rich why
don't you just have a pet that does that
for you oh you write you write your
[ __ ] one day and then you have a
[ __ ] easter egg coming out of your
vagina yeah a butt hole in a vagina
feels really good about production it's
extra like really tighter shut up yeah
that's disgusting
you don't even know you're saying what
would you do if you're I think the
ultimate vagina would have this you have
to [ __ ] the vagina right and then you
have your anal sphincter and then you
have a set of mouth lips
that's some [ __ ] constricting ass
Kegel wheel and these lips are like
these these lips imagine if they could
control it like mouth lips - yeah
different rhythms of like contracting
guys we don't like I like the mouth do
you think guys are crazy now for [ __ ]
imagine my whole entire inside [ __ ]
spins like it spins like it was a list
of all the future sex toys it all really
suck to come out of the dick
that [ __ ] would [ __ ] support suck out
the future supply of come like the ball
sacks would just deflate the balls
through the dick inside this it's like
boba you blow it to inflate it to
inflate it again
[ __ ] you Bobo submitted by neuron
there's a serial killer who thinks that
he could absorb vitamin C through his
brain so he would stack he's a comedian
- this sounds very interested is guy
seems like he's very smart this is a
survey shows that small business owners
feel cut off from the American Dream
what does that mean what's the American
dream so they're saying that the
American Dream is harder to reach than
ever before this was a new survey
conducted of 2,000 small and micro
business owners and so what the American
Dream consists of it's like five
elements yeah I don't know what they're
making dream is home ownership home
ownership for them to live how you
please okay starting your own business
having minimal debt retiring eventually
oh cool oh I'm like we're good yeah live
in the dream I could kind of feel this I
mean like I'm a small business owner but
then at the same time I feel like I
gotta keep saving more working more
investing more like it's not a loan it's
not enough to do it on one business like
and then yeah like I feel like this is
very common in our generation versus
like if you were a small business owner
in the 60s like not that I know what
they thought but then because the
economy was different like it's already
hard enough to own a home in LA like on
a regular job right but even as a
business owner now you're given this now
you're kind of like stuck like oh should
I invest more into this business and
then expand it and do all this stuff
before I buy a house I know what you
mean it was like before like you could
have one hustle and that one hustle can
be limited to a nine-to-five so you you
enjoy the freedoms of owning a business
but now if you have one hustle you kind
of have to like all of us have YouTube
channels or we're thinking about the
YouTube channel over the 905 or you end
up having two or three or whatever more
hustles and then all of those they
occupy your brain all the time you know
like Instagram isn't just your
nine-to-five like you're thinking about
Instagram maybe at 8:00 p.m. we're
your YouTube so it's like the American
dream wasn't as as like finite as before
where okay I do this then I get to relax
now it's kind of like everything is
embedded sometimes you're relaxing at
11:00 a.m. but then you're working at
like 10:00 p.m. and it's just like it's
just way more intertwined yeah they did
this like rice conversion thing of
universities and colleges like how much
they used to cost back in the day and
cars and like homes and if you convert
it to like in today's dollars it's it's
still way more like way way much more
than our like parents generation when
they're younger or when it was they
could get like a car with 24 months of
income or something like that
or like there's their specific numbers
but then it was dramatically like the
way that it's calculated it's like oh
[ __ ] like in two years you could pay
that off or if you get a home you could
afford it but not like have to spend
half of your paycheck on rent or
mortgage and in like if you think about
it I like to get a decent home in LA
let's say you're spending anywhere from
like 600,000 that's the average or 700
right and that's like if you want to
raise a family and all that [ __ ] you
need to have 20% of that down which is
couple hundred thousand dollars people
don't even have five thousand in their
bank account so like how you gonna are
you gonna save up that much money that's
a lot yeah it's out of those 2,000
seventy-eight percent said that they
would gladly take on more debt in order
to achieve the American Dream but that's
going against the dreamers because her
dream is to be debt-free I'll take no
more yeah is this having minimal debt
not that free I guess that's for the
house so then they're saying that 48%
consider the funding ecosystem around
small business broken it is kind of like
when we will operate the gym like you
you figure you think you just have like
a business model figure it out okay cool
we can ride this for a little bit and
all some laws change so they're bumping
up like the LA minimum wage which i
think is great for the employees because
you always want like all of your staff
to get paid more but the problem is now
you have to readjust yeah you can't
treat one issue at just one side is it
now okay cool then we'll raise the
prices then to make sure we can pay for
this but then now your customers are
like unhappy so it's like I feel like
the people that are at the top
they don't really I think if you're an
entrepreneur by yourself I think they
have they they have it easier and then
the people at the top that have already
made it they have it easier it's small
businesses right in the middle there's
that 5 people 10 people 20 people the
ones that want to grow the ones that
just set up shop and you know like it
takes a while for business to break-even
at least and then like technology and
stuff is getting better so like instead
of employing people they're just gonna
find like iPad cashiers or something
like that you're like oh sure my the
minimum wage is going up well instead of
hiring more people
I'll just have more technology but then
people need jobs still to you I heard
tell me if I'm wrong that raising the
minimum wage doesn't really do anything
because if you raise the minimum wage
the price of like everyday goods go up
so those people who are making minimum
wage are now spending more on everyday
goods that they're already buying yeah
so it's just like this vicious cycle of
minimum wage will never be that's how I
see it but a lot of the lawmakers I
don't know they might wait they probably
know way more than me but from how I see
it they I think they're just doing it
just to make people happy so people will
yeah they have a good association with
this person's name so now when they're
vine
that office more people will vote for
him because they're only viewing it like
in television like oh yeah
mayor mayor Lucas he raised the minimum
wage and he wants to be governor now
dude I love him so much but realize the
milk prices went up yeah you don't but
you don't I like oh [ __ ] my car just
doubled in price because of what this
[ __ ] did cuz then I'll just
think like well thankfully I got a pay
raise whatever I can afford it you know
it's just I think everyone now in
general everyone is struggling like the
small business owner to everyone except
for the biggest companies and mmm I
heard the reason why this is happening
twos is a lot of the money that should
be going back into America and taxes and
stuff like that is being offshored and
then it doesn't come back so like let's
say Google or whatever they pay some of
them pay like a thousand bucks in
corporate taxes and we're talking about
billion-dollar companies that's amazing
it's amazing if you're Google yeah yeah
but it's not for us because now what
happens is like someone's got to pay
those taxes right so now the
responsibility goes down to the citizens
and the small business owners and
everyone else because then we don't have
like the lawyers and everybody to pay to
kind of maneuver our money that way our
accountants and lawyers it's like
they're not that sophisticated and we
don't have hundreds of thousands of
dollars
what's shady dude oh yeah and it's super
shady but that's what ends up happening
and so like you know when these laws
pass where it's like oh oh yeah we're
gonna we're gonna tax the rich what
they're doing is they're taxing people
that make over $100,000 they're not rich
but for poor people they see oh this guy
makes 300 grand he's rich let's tax some
more or or let's let's us if you make a
million even let's let's tax some but
they're still getting [ __ ] it's these
people the top top people and they're
companies they're getting away with a
[ __ ] ton of money unpopular opinion I
mean everyone's underpaid I feel like
sometimes you would have focus on like
the lower class that are underpaid but I
feel like every class under like you
have to be underpaid its top to bottom
what people don't realize is like like
everybody now is way underpaid compared
to our parents generation there's a lot
of reasons like people go oh it's
because women now were
or like it's because of this or whatever
which has some truth but I don't know
because the population expanded to since
that time so one of the things in the
past they would say is like Oh back in a
day women didn't work so there's only
only the man work that's why there's
there wasn't a surplus of people in the
workplace but then if women were to they
also earn which is stimulating the
economy but I don't know man it's just
how do you even it's how do you even
measure it it's so crazy but going back
to this I'm just curious like like what
are people saying really well they're
just saying that because of the economy
and the way things are happening like
they feel like they need to take out way
more loans to keep their business
running or which then makes it harder
for them to reach the American Dream
because they're constantly being in debt
I can see that the ecosystem around
small business is just not really
happening I'm done working well that's
so true
[Music]